welcome to this video on playing digital
in a five-minute game let's see I've got
the caro-kann let's go for the Bronstein
dozen okay 93 93 can can really be
tackled with this early aggression it's
um
instantly thrown white off a bit so
black has got some active possibilities
okay hmm
is he trying Bishop g5 maybe
trying to irritate him a bit here night
before maybe I can do that
we probably gain the bishop town cost
sometime though yeah should I keep it
yeah it is slow it is the slow kind of
plane so should be okay
and now yeah he threatens to play
discovery with the night but I don't I
don't see it it's being so dangerous
yeah
can I take bishop takes a three-year
it's very close Bishop III takes Queen
takes King be one Queen b3 check that
sets the point of the slip hmm that's
very close to working hmm maybe Bishop
c2 at the end okay he can use the night
away but it's probably not helping so
much
now maybe night be one night be one with
the idea to take on a three with the
night ah
I've got Bishop eat before okay I've got
Bishop before me it was night a - I've
got Queen a four that's clearly good and
night before I have Queen d5 and even
here I've got Bishop before actually to
be honest but Queen a4 is probably the
the easier move directly threatening
made on c2 and it's not so clear what he
is doing now to prevent that the maybe
move the bishop okay yes guess to to
here
that's let's get the Knight to d5 or
maybe to see for both them both
dangerous yeah this Bishop under that
one g6 is exceptionally strong of course
I could also play rook h5 this is an
attractive looking move switching over
to b5
okay
hmm yeah I should probably just stated
and now maybe it's here rook t5 195 it's
both good time
it's not don't see a direct way to to
win this okay and just let's just get
the Queen's off and windows endgame it's
a pawn and a very nicely coordinated
position
I'm trying to get the e5 pawn see 596
check ok should I yeah I probably should
first cover that now let's let's
consider Knight to f5 ok this can be
withdrawn now
I can go through d7 that's that's bad
I've got the eight though that's very
important that I get them to see for
porn check
check-check
yeah it's a race but I think I'm cooking
up night B 3 2 D 2 this is made even Wow
yeah this was too convincing after the
start it it was it was very tricky I
should have won this rather easily after
I got the able to pawn but played this
sloppily obviously white resigned
I mean okay even this is a very nice end
game but of course the game shouldn't
really the game shouldn't really
continue okay here I can take because
check this is check just good for black
it's not completely clear but it's three
pawns and then attack we have Knight b6
coming and this idea and I don't know it
looks pretty good so he didn't he didn't
do that he just played here and this
this really should be over quickly but I
didn't manage to to finish this off c5
yeah here here there your computer wants
to do this
now sometimes you should really just
look look a bit of a bit bit closer yeah
I saw the move but I've heard of what I
forgot is that I thought you just place
him and I just take tit - yeah of course
and this means I either get the get the
Ponyo for nothing or he must take and
this is completely over I mean rock tea
- if I was hanging and so on this is
just terrible
okay this was the easiest and of course
this is much weaker going to the endgame
the endgame is obviously better for
black but check it it still needs to be
needs to be played I'm not not quite
quite sure if all this was so brilliant
I mean this this can easily be a V okay
for white yeah the computer gives white
advantage here I mean it's it's very
tricky to play in time check with time
pressure my points are also dangerous
this seems to be a mistake
you know quite clear I am with the check
it wants to play h4 and white wins yeah
h5 g v h6 this is really quick yeah
amazing check yeah okay here black is
winning yeah it happens with this little
time that you screw up just like that
and here black is is basically mating
already yeah was I should have fun ended
the game right right after the opening
but I didn't manage okay thanks for
watching